star was loved and cherished by her aunt
alicia
[Music]
and by her great
she were just a
bubbly little smiley baby
come here
she was adored too by her regular
babysitter holly
she loved playing or dancing she never
liked toys or playing with like toys
she'd much rather like play hide and
seek
star do you love your mums
but star's playful nature seems to have
abandoned her in this clip with mother
frankie smith smith admitted in court
she'd been a cruel mum but the jury
decided it was smith's lover savannah
brockhill on the right who beat star to
death in september 2020 while smith was
found guilty of causing or allowing the
death of her daughter
footage of star with her killer brock
hill is unnerving unlike with her aunt
starr doesn't kiss back brock hill's
apparent affection is mixed with insults
pretty good he was spoiled pretty good
round around the garden like a teddy
bear star's great grandparents who
looked after her for 11 weeks earlier in
the year had become increasingly worried
everywhere
serious girl
deadly
well we were hearing things like she
were being slam choked you know we
didn't know what that was it's something
to do with you to grab them around the
neck and throw them on to bed or
something it's something you do if you
were
karate or something like but it's not
sort of the thing you'd associate with a
10 month 11 month old baby like on
facebook david posted a picture of what
star looked like living with him
alongside a picture he'd seen of star
with bruising what's going on frankie he
asked look i says i'll come every time
you've got star
she comes back covered in bruises so we
keep seeing pictures of her we've seen
the light you know
if i'm walking and she's covered in
bruises she says all kids get roses
yeah but i said it's like she didn't
have any bruises once you were with us
numerous family and friends made
referrals to social services about brock
hill and smith's treatment of star
including david and his partner anita
but the women told caseworkers the
complaints were malicious the bruises
accidental authorities closed the case
without telling david and anita you
communicated with them but they never
got back to they never got back to us
and they never cross referenced anything
nope
never heard the thing though
do you say do you see do you see that as
a failing
yes i mean there was i mean the
conversation i mean
anita that told me at the time because i
was shocked she says i said to the lady
look
we're concerned we don't want another
baby pee on his hands and the lady said
how do you mean
baby p was 17 months old when he died
after suffering more than 50 injuries
starr was a month younger when she was
killed
smith and brock hill both claimed to be
out of the room when starr was beaten
and left with catastrophic abdominal
injuries but they were both in the flat
and they googled how to bring a baby out
of shock 11 minutes before brock hill
had this 999 conversations
and she started to be sick so i led her
on the floor yeah like cpr position
started to run runner back
and she started to lose
lose breath
so i performed cpr on us
when paramedics arrived it was too late
a post-mortem found the toddler had
other injuries including a fractured
skull and leg
those who'd seen star had flagged their
concerns including frankie's friend and
babysitter holly it was heartbreaking
the last time i saw her
it was yeah it was horrible
what describe how she was just
distant
she was very
clingy
but not a like
a good clinger
it was very much like she wouldn't let
go of me
and just
yeah it wasn't
like
i've never seen a depressed baby but
that is what it was like it was
i think
that day i saw her i think will scare me
for the rest of my life
after star's death the evidence of
cruelty stacked up the lover brockhill
was contracted to provide out of hours
security at a recycling plant on this
industrial estate in doncaster sometimes
she brought starr with her on the job
clearly it's highly unusual for a
security worker to bring a toddler to
work on an industrial estate and when
police discovered that's what brockhill
had done they did a cctv trawl and
discovered footage of her beating star
21 times
the day before star's death cctv showed
her mother dragging her through this
part of bradford like a puppet the child
crying when trying to walk but when
smith suggested taking her to hospital
brockhill said starr was just having a
tantrum we now know she had a fractured
leg
after the recent killing of six-year-old
arthur le binjo hughes tortured by his
father and stepmother starr's case
raises more questions about the
protection of children
her smile and her laugh i'll never
forget that
it was such a new unique laugh
what makes this doubly shocking is that
star had loving extended family multiple
alerts flagged the dangers
[Music]
but somehow that didn't lead to the
action that could have saved her
jason farrell sky news